اجهزه الامن الروسيه تعمل على التحقيق
فيما اذا كان للاستخبارات الغربيه ضلوع في
احداث الرابع والعشرين من يونيو
[موسيقى]
اخبار العالم
بالجزيره مرحبا بكم في اول ظهور له بعد
انتهاء تصعيد
ان حكمته تقوم بتعزيز الامن يقول ان موسكو
تبحث فيما اذا كانت الاستخبارات الغربيه
ضالعه في المساله ونيابه الروسيه تعلن ان
قائد فاجن لا يزال خاضعا للملاحقه
القضائيه
يتنياهو يطالب بالعمل على اشتثاث فكره
اقامه الدوله الفلسطينيه الرئاسه
الفلسطينيه تقول ان التصريحات تظهر رفض
اسرائيل الشرعيه الدوريه وحماس تدعو
السلطه لاعاده النظر في مسار المفاوضات
ووقف التنسيق الامني بعد معارك ضاريه
واعلانه انسحاب قواته الجيش السوداني يقول
ان قوات الدعم السريع استولت على مقر
رئاسه قوات الاحتياطي المركزي بالخرطوم
وحكومه اقليم النيل الازرق تؤكد التصدي
لهجوم من قوات الحركه الشعبيه شمال على
مواقع للجيش جنوبيه الاقلي حجاج بيت الله
الحرام يواصلون التوجه الى مشعل مينا
لقضاء يوم الترويه حيث يبيت الحجاج في
منها حتى بزوغ شمس يوم التاسع من ذي الحجه
ووزاره الداخليه السعوديه تبدا تنفيذ خطه
مروريه لاداره افواج الحجاج الذين يتوقع
ان يصل عددهم الى نحو مليونين و300 الف
حاج الى اللقاء